another busy weekend in the valley means
another weekend where traffic is bumper
to bumper heading back to southern
california thanks for staying with us
here at 6 30. i'm denise valdez and i'm
brian loftis it's nothing new you need
to have a full tank right for drivers
but it's top of mind for some elected
officials they're hoping the giant
infrastructure bill sitting in congress
means a potential fix heather mills
explains
everyone can agree the road from barstow
to the nevada state line can get nasty
but how to fix it and who's going to pay
for it that's a little more tricky mayor
goodman says california should pony up
we had friends come in from l.a it took
him three and a half hours
nine
going back
nine
you've probably had a similar experience
which is why las vegas mayor carolyn
goodman has her foot on the accelerator
she wants to widen the 15 on the
california side it's gridlock and this
is ridiculous for us selfishly it's
about tourism and getting those people
easily in from the southern california
area but it goes beyond that mayor
goodman cites nationwide commerce and
freight these are the connecting roads
and the key is bar stood as state line
the city of las vegas estimates it'll
cost 1.8 billion dollars to widen 114
miles of interstate the nationwide cost
of the current congestion though 3
billion a year clark county commissioner
tick segregates it is a mess you see
that line you think who would ever come
back here after going through that but
he says nevada should foot the bill
since our state is the beneficiary of
tourism dollars i think it's in our best
interest to make sure that road happens
no matter who pays for it and if we have
to pay for it from our budget or from
our infrastructure money it's money well
spent no matter who pays for it caltrans
is responsible their take quote
currently the department has no plans
for this type of effort caltrans is
citing a fix it first approach within
california and instead are working with
brightline west for high-speed passenger
rail to reduce congestion back to you